you
so here is the situation where we are
today you and we have made a significant
improvement over the years but we still
have a lot of problems but the street is
that more no more enterprise or users
are adopting hadoop as their mission
critical systems they use Hadoop to do
more and more things and they of course
if expose more the more they talk to put
more data on the Hadoop cluster but at
the same time they expose them enough to
to part of all users previously is just
like a view in a scientist that you know
enterprise or in for 70 years
there are prototypes but then now not
all not just those users but also
general users such like the data analyst
melodies or business users are using
Hadoop to to achieve their enterprise
functions so one of the typical accuse
cage use case is that in our hospital we
know that they are in our house provides
an insight into the business but the
window scope of the data that we are
experience today traditional data
warehouse just done in skill so that's
why we naturally take heart open and say
attention to 'extra
this team in our house beside the same
problem but the contacts are for big
data so because of this and also because
of the familiarity interface Saeko right
we become phenomenal phenomenal
phenomena because the sequel provide it
stuff the things that we are from URI we
are all coming from the relational world
but a we are steer our need of a
different work and for big data in the
staircase
so it looks like I get through a terms
of flights faster so but there are
problems too so so one thing is that
it's about security so in terms of
prides because the only thing equally
sensitive with a daunting lot of
protective data in our show so that's
what internal force there are already
external force that's the government
right so there are not a lot of
governmental regulations that are
require certain security measures to be
taken to some kind of the data so so we
have the laws like paper PIR face lock
on the other hand the haouka right it's
a category has their security problems
so to a certain extent and this problem
has an infirmity in the federal action
pattern so if we see how to raise the
brink of are we secure that I already
imagine that that there are going to be
involved and even more users of I do so
because of this security you have to
become to a top priority for a lot of
the components in the Hadoop ecosystem
so nevertheless we still have this the
problem is it so the progress including
okay even though people are around the
world working on the screening you prove
the security but they're hot on poop so
you have negative now the different
component implement a different security
mechanisms and but the to make things
worse but different component that can
access the same theta right so you have
to give you how some certain theta first
thing that can be market or to to a
coyote or or be accessed by a people
scream to or buying some of em are jobs
so and the module was born of
although the trust so I still have our
martini and we want to make cotton work
first but then we certify to solve a
security problem so because of this
sense of there's always a bad call for
security in order either frame for frame
work applications you know in a horrid
ecosystem so it's a very similar to the
power windows windows system operation
system become the same path that the
window system has gone through so maybe
you argue to build a more information
about security concept especially in
Hadoop overcome hard to port so security
there are most of you when we talk about
security there are four components of
all four aspects of security so that's a
authentication authorization data
protection and governing oddity so I was
application so it's too high too high 35
who you are right so when you whenever
you access the system or the system want
to know who you are
so what whether you are you are really
what you claim you are so so so in the
earlier sort of in the early stages of
how to write them they becoming
something we have we had was so when I
was isolated ahahah kloster in the only
certain user can access is network so we
provided an D the network layer and
another organelle in our so we assumed
that if you have access to the other
cluster you are trusted you are guard
were you gonna say to them so
and you're on accordion right so for
your eyes actor if you find if you tell
me to buy the kind of wholesome so that
place is going to be at you if your
username is defined and your local your
kind of machine it's the username of
your higher machine so we know so you
wouldn't know how secure that is so how
to put it on you produced a strong
authentication as a Kerberos so and
another carbo's is false indication but
for most enterprises they already have
they are authentication systems such as
LDAP or Active Directory so you know a
lot of cases learn in the hard work they
do you have our demo activity are
actually integrated with the Kerberos so
they work nicely together so we should
provide a single point of food and of
course once the authentication theme
plays people like you conveniently they
want to sing course I am so I'm not sure
how how reality probably or it is today
but I think that's a lot of the course
that the community is trying to achieve
so you know video more information
crumbles so it does provide a strong
education it are it also provides a
future authentication it's not just the
server authenticates the user but it
also allow the user to awesome or client
and essentially the service so they
might become protector against like a
use talking or replay attacks and the
user or service has a purple screen
supported print so it so for instance
has a credential individually in terms
also like a first service its Marquis
tab that's where it is for your your
keenya by oh that's your credential for
you you your the forum user is it is
password so the second is the background
for authentication of security is
authentication
it was the third teach army what you can
do
so once you are in it but the data means
you can do whatever you want to right so
so in determining what you can access so
the your means or the existing
mechanisms of Hadoop provides its T in
HTML Posca style with the write
permission at the like a $3 main user
group our word it's cost greater because
it's on the on the file data file or
folder so of course other components
also provides authorization such as the
M R and it has acute cues that you can
determine decide the hooker for the jobs
on their own particular field or HP is
like that you can either have the OTC
house on the family company level on
cable mo and criminal to impose further
providing scale their own authorization
so impersonation is also sometimes it
actually is very widely used so when
when a service has no means to do the
authorization so I'd say okay I cannot
determine whether you can do or not but
um let me dedicate instead of your
request to the underlying system such as
the fire system to see whether you can
do something
so the service packages above the
protection so in other words a pretty
great machine if my machine is true like
pertechnetate that's all you mean that
they don't get a compromise or stop
stallin or so it need to make sure that
a delighted still I use the part to an
authorized the users
so the impression is the mechanism and
part of today provides provision are on
the energy in transit so there are
tragedies of the data when the denied
the trans transferring in the network
but we are from me they Taft dinner
production for Dana and the rest which
means that when the data is stored in a
storage such as the fire system so today
if Adam has no no encryption on that but
there is a active project going on and
there are a lot of discussions so so if
you are interested follow that
discussion there on auto for fan for
there because this is a really complex
problem show and once you do equip the
right you were dismissed and you have
the vanity this case of your go through
the case right so and so all those
things exciting but a very complicated
so current leader only relies on the OS
level encryption the last aspect of the
security is the dominance of audience so
which is a provided proof that the
weather group data actually can
compromise or kind of protected as
expected so again you have word its
implement component for component for
example DFS and reduce to provide some
basic
auditing on your knob and you can
in fact you can be checked and are a
bunch of kind a destructive a party girl
what appears is your plan so it has a
basic audience support and Kirsty Apache
woody
Orson provides how your article zeros
for your service usage so now it's a
poverty in 13th century so century is
not for everything but I only for how to
authorization so that's the second
aspect if you mind previous slide so so
I assume that you are authenticated and
so again so right now the current
situation is that its existing
authorizing different components in
particular different times and so
because it is so complicated or
sometimes very inconvenient so a lot of
times the enterprise just a protein are
protected but that's not a long-term
solution so what an enterprise really is
authorizing component that works across
your enterprise the form all the
components and it should be a use of use
in a fine-grained and a row paste
so I will talk about about a row based
next so as the way service entry provide
authorization for for many couple
modules for many components like an
Apache
hi search or Impala in affion so I know
it has in Abby's the key requirements
for
for my role based access control such as
secure fine phase fine-grained or row
based organization and it has the mote
mote italic
heavens esupport yes it opens house the
source it has been you know in the you
can return project or for over a year
and it has brought ecosystem support so
here are the benefits of if you use a
century so you can you can star your
fear mom confidence targeted sensitive
data in Hadoop and you can the extended
your heart attacks from all users and
you can comply with the nicer regular
tanker company regulations so so here's
what a century can do for you in a
provide fine-grained authorization so
you can find great to be inside the not
just the fire or folder it's a it's you
can provide also access control on
servers like the databases tables of
videos in tax collections so depends on
what I'm wishing you have so you can
define your server resources to protect
so it is row paste which means that the
ministry to work on work out the rows
like that actual functional role that
you play in your enterprise rather than
the teacher like the Murray wrote our
concepts Ranka created with this paper
on top of them that innovates the
inspector so it's a row based
Diagnostics watch analysis the morning
which means you okay you can dedicate
your certain authorized that I mean
you're civil
several our components to to put other
are the visitors so together you can so
it could be maintained a better so that
we don't burn one tie it down
so here is the architecture of mass
entry
so in the Meno is a parsing engine
that's how that's a one where the work
is actually done so it did you graduate
so integer value it's so far out there
is every pass the basically they we're
giving you answers yes or no but of
based on what in a based on the things I
work up next but basically your idea
with these rules you define a lot of
authorization rules and further top is a
week or the pioneered answer the first
component provides I sense a button you
can you can use a cup of your
applications such as Impala
I'm sort or sold out if you have other
applications that you want you you want
to use template and you can say a
percent you can provide that you the
binding
are you are you need to do is just use
that upon your new year and in your
application so on a lower cover is the
where the policy is gonna be called a
policy provider so right now you can
start off by on or on database so on
rubia
we're talking all about this part that's
the that's a new so previously we only
have it is so you can start your policy
you know toka more HDFS file
so here is a century in action in a
context of the sacred I've got higher so
point Dahmer I say you for higher wisdom
because it's good incentive for us a
transition so what happens to you for
highways it was sequel you nobody did
the grammar and you're the constructor
of STR syntax tree up there statement of
tree so that we already invoked simply
in and check recently say okay this is
the art of your time this is the new
authorities of whether you are trying to
do so whether I should allow whether we
should allow this procedure or not so
centrally apply backs either yes or no
you fool
everything is good sewing to go further
and to process the process temporary
so here it's the the component Afghan
involved I am you know you're defying
defying your authorization policy so we
now users and a user group or membership
that's where so a user and what groups
that you belong to and resources that's
where what the things that you want
protect on fire people privilege is an
action on resources or role wrote that's
basically a beast of privileges so we
were talking a little bit more on each
so user so you're hearing we assume that
accuser I mean we assume the user is
authenticated and you you need the user
identification identity is they actually
have taken from the session context so
that's a program that giving you
convenient samples to the system or to
the user so you know from full
membership so these are you you need to
find outside the city's policy it's a
junior you that is from your ankle your
user directory such as our tap or active
directory of sometimes from the hdfs the
fire system so this can also sometimes
be available from your from the your
session contacts resources is the data
that you want to protect that could be a
file or directory HDFS or it could be
like a four billion high or just a
general URI or so resource can be here
write code that's why you can say okay I
or II so the super to me pony cart is
top now Orton lost to a several hour to
be managed by client separator and
visitors so privilege as I said is a
actually operation associated with the
resource it only exists in a role in
you cannot grant an action or
preventative tool to add user or user
group but you need to find privileges in
a row so so the privilege is the
examples my column is whether select a
given table view or create a table a
database or are you comparing our search
connection or you continue to file or
directory' you know file system so I
think there's an example that's like
caption so this is you find a privilege
it basically is it from the left side is
the resources and on the right side is
the action that's what you would say if
you use the fire based policy roast is a
cracking of privileges so you broke now
allow for many privileges so in the
define that you know something policy
and you and you can correct row not
approve individual privileges 22 a loser
bro so here are the examples on the
other side of the Geoscience team row
and on the right side it's one or many
privileges so this here is a group or
romantic it's where you branch the
privilege to to users so you say that
this user provoking health is privileged
Ortiz this role so for example a user
fee not true analysts so and it can have
peace of privileges so it's also a
one-to-many relationship so here are
some examples the left side W to sign is
the user groups so it's a the you know
probes have this rose
so Road evaluation has a ratio in the
reverse slide on the on a Segway example
so so it'll go like this so so something
we were first chairing a single points
that you observe
that's the users identity what ropes the
European actual so we gotta at least of
the user groups from the you're not
directory and Water Resources the the
user is trying to access it's a file or
folder or connection or or just some
some directory and up with the resources
access is to get a rate right or very
and then the final check wanna be a
psychologist does the any of the users
groups have a role that grant the user
to access access the cayman resources so
you can enter it yes so that in when you
are three nine four eight nine ten to go
through our whites it does stop you
right there
so that's how the access control works
alright so that's pretty much you want
to have butter them more exciting for me
it's the next my my colleague should
really give you the recent development
or the things that we just achieved
recently and hopefully you will get some
insight from there so I will come back
for Q&A
thank you
hi everyone my name is rabia i'm talking
mostly about recent developments in the
artists entry project so as my colleague
xufu mentioned so a few years back there
were clusters in companies and they were
just like handful of engineers using
Hadoop clusters so the question of you
know how do we provide authorization
control and security was less free on
any question to ask
so now thanks to you know rapid Hadoop
adoption across the companies now we
have like you know hundreds of users are
you know trying to use the Hadoop
clusters and show you the data but we
also need to make sure we don't expose
all the data to everyone
and her no clusters are no more like you
know like a POC clusters in production
hosteen sensitive data so it's even more
important do we know predicting it down
and find great you know access control
so coming back to the latest development
of a quick overview of what we have in
CD age 5 and what we should bring in
fine the CD 85 1 so in in the old world
century used to work with quality files
so what that meant was you have a super
mentioned you have a set of roles and
you have set of privileges assigned to
these drawers so you have you have you
can have either one policy file or you
can have you know tree or policy fights
for in hi Impala and search so that was
all working good but imagine you have
like you know thousands of tables
my house and the policy files really
gets you know very difficult to manage
so one of the things which we walked out
was you know sequel kind you know of
Oracle my sequel kind of interface where
you can grant a new privileges to users
so that is what the century service is
about so if you look at the picture so
sentry service is basically a trim
service which basically talks to a
back-end DB storage where you can store
all of your privileges and then we also
have our sentry service client in Java
and thrift so the high binding basically
the hype the life basically provides a
sequel syntax for grant and revoke so
you can create roles you can grant the
roles to the groups and you can grant
privileges to the role so all of these
privilege data is stored in the back in
teaming and let's see how different our
services interact with the simply
service
so height seven to basically talks to us
a hive sentry binding which lives in the
century so it can either talk to the
file hold a fine base provider or it can
talk talk to the database provider so
database provided basically if users the
centrally service client and it talks to
the Sentry service for all its requests
and coming to the Impala Boyd Impala is
a sequel engine which is you know near
interactive so we you really have to
serve the privilege request fast
so how Impala interacts with sentry
has a service called Impala catalog
server which basically pulls the
privilege data and cashes it on each
node so that if a lady has a local copy
of the privileges which you can look up
done so this is the flow for the
Impala
so if mother uses our cash based policy
provider by the way feel free to stop me
if you have any questions in between and
another big feature we worked on
recently is a high meta storage security
so what that means is so there are
multiple ways of accessing the hymen of
story the most widely used popular ways
are through high or Impala
so both hybrid Impala provides a sequel
interface for the users so you can just
do a select star or table which is you
know created out of you know a semi
structured data so and there are not
just - impalas like you know sequel it's
a hybrid Impala you can also you know
right big scripts which work on the high
Minister data so Pig scripts you know
essentially read the data and you know
converts the script into of MapReduce
job for you
so you don't have to write low-level
MapReduce programs and this is also up
so the zoom H can lock something called
a catalog which basically talks to hi
better start to get all the information
of the metadata
stolen - of your house so it knows you
know where exactly each table is
actually present on the HDFS and it
knows other information like what are
the columns this database
you know one of the tables this database
has columns the schema and one of the
five formats are using and so on so it
basically contains all the metadata
about your tables and databases so peak
uses typically you know peak users who
want to use - house data typically use
each cap we'll get all that information
even in my users can use each catalog to
get all the material contribution and
there's also with each camp
it's basically we can write rest rest
based apps using web hCAP - we know
create and do all metadata operations
are using which a can't so there
was a sir as you can see there are lots
of you know entry points to - a star
apart from sequel engines so so yes the
new feature here is the earlier the my
meter store was access control holy
through high Impala and search
now the I meant us toward there's a
plucky exciting plug-in indictment of
stones which would also provide you
access control in hybrid of stem cells
what that means is your peak users and
my users can also will also go through
same thing one thing to note is the same
to plug in indictment of stone is not as
robust as no simply plugins in hives
over to any pile of an example it right
now it right now protects only the read
read path for the meditator so that is
the thing and one other small thing to
note as as you may know Heights over to
for example is a service right so all of
the interactions all of those sequel
queries which you give against hikes
overdue on perform as a service user
random and on in the user space
right so it's very easy to you know
manage that so what we recommend is
hives over to owns all of the pain of
Zeta so what will you come into seven
seven zero on the bait house data where
only high and it Paula can read right
so naturally high of HDFS theta is like
you know restricted from rest of the
world so in the case of play what
happens is all the queries all the
scripts are performed and we use it so
I'm sorry if I'm writing a big script of
the high might have stored data is on
accessed as share of them a super user
in that case you know the cage TFS
permissions gets tricky
so right now sentry doesn't handle HDFS
permissions when you are going through
pick back read your road although if
you're going through a higher you pal
around on the perform perform all the
operations are performed at the super
users so you are taking care of without
HDFS functions yeah so essentially this
feature would allow even the big users
and among users to you know use
centering so this is about the new
features I'm gonna cure you a quick demo
very quick demo
so this is a Florida man in children of
managed cluster and also some of the
improvements in the recent past cells
you know how to be configured symmetric
how do we make it easy to configure and
get started so right now it's very very
simple
you basically have to we know start a
sentry service and most of the
configurations are you know
pre-configured didn't our router manager
so once you have your sentry service up
and running or you have to do is though
you basically have to say okay my height
depends on this century service that is
power so once you say your hive is
depending on Centauri service all the
configurations are going to be
configured for you to make the path work
and same goes for Impala as well
so you say Ambala is using century
service and all on the queries which go
through Paulo would now go through
century as well so it's that signal so
once you have your now cluster bomb
figure
so I'm gonna show you simple examples on
how an admin can grant and revoke
privileges and as you mentioned on the
hive side on the DB model side we allow
privileges at 11:00 so an admin can have
all the privileges cleaned right on some
other which means an admin can create
new databases dump data are integrated
tables and so on and then you can also
have users have access on database level
so you can have maybe you know a
sensitive database which only the
certain set of people are allowed to
access so you can have a database of it
and then you can also have access table
level and of you live it so even with
the table and Mueller then you can have
either select axis insert axis or off so
usually select axis gives you permission
to read the data insert axis gives you
privileged to you know down date on to
the table and all basically gives you
privileges to alter though you know take
up our metadata so let's go ahead and
you know give some privileges to users
by the way this is a card rose cluster
so the very high server to hive server
to all indicators or user is using the
Kerberos cash credit or cash so I'm
going to kill you to admin user
so basically pre created some rules here
so there's our db1 Allroad I've been
drove and it'll be one select row so we
can see what these roles actually have
privileges to do
so the admin role as you can see has you
know all privileges on all the databases
so that's what we want you want an admin
user who can do I usually you know
please write everything
so as I'm logged in as an admin user I
should be able to you know create a new
database
so this user has been successfully able
to create a new database
so the db1 if you look at the DB one all
row so there are two privileges act they
can remove one of those so it says I
have all privileges on TV one it also
has all privileges in default which we
can go and revoke let's see how do we
book a privilege
so we removed all on database deport
from royalty banal because it bit
doesn't make sense so let's again you
know look at the grounds we have so as
you can see the you know the packet
database got refreshed and only DB one
primitives are there here in the tool so
as you can imagine if I now assign this
role to a user that user will only be
you know do any operations on that
particular database and he'll not be
able to you know see any date tables or
really need a berth in any other place
so I'll go ahead and assign the role to
a user and let's see what happens if the
user tries to create a take people
through another database
so as you can see as an admin user and
I'm able to see the tables immediately
for database and same will not work if I
you know log in as well user who doesn't
have privileges
so as you can see this user only has
privileges on TV one
so if I there were show tables on the v4
database all the tables will be filtered
out they are not increasing back to this
user
and this user tries to create a database
center would throw an exception saying
you know you don't have enough
privileges
and this user has all the privileges of
database so it was even to successfully
create a table in the database so it's
it's very intuitive and it's very
similar to the sequel traditional sequel
well how do you plan to provoke the
village's so yeah so this is how you can
you know set up a cluster with entry and
you know get started and give the
privileges yeah yeah will be available
here to take questions
so sentry so high better store so high
better shirt and hikes ever do both
talks into service not have it down so
in the case of high - tourist heights /
- there will be one call for each query
if you think in terms of for long you
know for what use cases we use highest
that night might not be very you know
visible yeah I wouldn't think it will
take a lot of time depends on you know
you have an ability of sentry service of
course but if the Impala won't ask me
you know as we want real-time results
you know privileges are cached so it
should we take any time at all right so
in memory
very refreshing so that's the important
problem to soy so so right now there is
no higher availability sentry
but yeah that is something we are
working on yes there are some customers
interaction
they will add new lemon right now yeah
yeah the current solution is sort of you
use acquired views so you have
predicates in your query and that sort
of gives you some degree of security but
that's my point I really don't know but
it's an early detection we would really
like to get it through CN Phi and it
isn't but yeah uh the bottom level
security and whole level security are
two things on our lecture on nearest
road map so yeah perfect Scott is here
but you don't quote me every technique I
mean its accuracy in that so yeah it's
open source if you want it comes fast
yeah you can find the data and put some
pressure on that
like in a butcher shop nothing that not
directly yeah I think the most of no
important things in our strata of course
it Rizza open source project so anybody
who wants a feature contributor request
features so a few things we've seen in
the painters you know even today if we
want to allow we can admire users to you
know access files in the hybrid us it's
not really straightforward because of
its JMS permissions so there's this
devious permissions which you maintain
using extra decals and you have senti
partitions so you have to give them in
sync so the short term winner goal is to
somehow make HDFS maybe talk to sentry
you know have one source of truth have
one source of one place where users can
even manage their permissions
all right thank you